de la obra maestra y revelar
lo que podría haber debajo.
Esta resultó ser la pintura más importante
que tenemos en Italia de Leonardo da Vinci
y miren estas hermosas imágenes de rostros que nadie ha visto
en cinco siglos. Miren estos retratos.
Son magníficos. Se ve a Leonardo en acción.
Se ve la genialidad de su creación, directamente
en la capa base del panel, y ver
esta genialidad y encontrar —-diría más bien—-
un elefante. (Risas) Gracias a este elefante,
aparecieron más de 70 imágenes nuevas, nunca vistas en siglos.
Fue una revelación. Llegamos a entender
y demostrar que el revestimiento marrón que vemos hoy
no pertenece a Leonardo da Vinci, que nos dejó
sólo los otros dibujos, que durante cinco siglos
no pudimos ver y hoy lo vemos gracias a la tecnología.
Bien, la tableta. Bueno, pensamos, tenemos
el placer, el privilegio de ver todo esto,
de hallar estos descubrimientos, ¿y si lo compartimos con los demás?
Por eso pensamos en una aplicación de realidad aumentada
en una tableta. Les mostraré un simulacro
de lo que podríamos hacer, cualquiera de nosotros,
en un museo.
Supongamos que vamos a un museo con una tableta, ¿sí?
Y apuntamos con la cámara de la tableta
a la pintura que nos interesa ver, por ejemplo ésta.
¿Sí? Haré clic, apretaré pausa,
y ahora vuelvo a Uds. y en el momento en que la imagen
o —-debería decir la cámara-—- capturó la pintura,
se cargaron las imágenes que vieron allí arriba
en el dibujo. Así que vean.
Podemos, como decíamos, ampliarla. Y luego desplazarnos.
¿Sí? Vayamos a descubrir el elefante.
Todo lo que necesitamos es un dedo. Limpiamos
y vemos el elefante. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)
¿Sí? Y si queremos
podemos seguir desplazándonos para encontrar, por ejemplo
en la escalera, que toda la iconografía va a cambiar.
Hay una gran cantidad de laicos reconstruyendo,
de las ruinas de un viejo templo, un nuevo templo
y aparecen un montón de figuras. ¿Las ven?
Esto no es sólo una curiosidad, sino que cambia
no sólo la iconografía tal como la ven, sino la iconología,
el significado de la pintura,
y creemos que esta es una manera genial, muy fácil,
de que todo el mundo tenga acceso a, se vuelva más
protagonista del propio descubrimiento y no un mero
espectador pasivo, como lo somos al recorrer las salas
interminables de los museos.
(Aplausos)
Otro concepto es la historia clínica digital, que suena
muy obvia si hablamos de pacientes reales
pero si se trata de obras de arte, desafortunadamente,
nunca lo hemos considerado.
Bueno nuevamente creemos que esto debería ser el comienzo,
el primer paso hacia la conservación real
que nos permita realmente explorar y entender
todo lo relacionado al estado de nuestra conservación,
la técnica, los materiales y también si, cuándo y por qué
deberíamos restaurar o, mejor dicho, intervenir
el entorno que circunda a la pintura.
Nuestra visión es redescubrir
el espíritu del Renacimiento; crear una nueva disciplina
en la que la ingeniería del patrimonio cultural sea en realidad
un símbolo de la amalgama entre arte y ciencia.
Definitivamente necesitamos una nueva generación de ingenieros
dispuestos a hacer este tipo de trabajo
y redescubrir estos valores, estos valores culturales
que tanto necesitamos, en especial hoy.
Si queremos resumirlo en una palabra,
esto es lo que tratamos de hacer:
tratamos de darle un futuro a nuestro pasado
para tener un futuro.
En tanto vivamos una vida de curiosidad y pasión,
habrá un poco de Leonardo en cada uno de nosotros. Gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)